ça marche bien alors jean marie on va
faire maintenant un petit interview une
petite interview a redit view c'est
formidable c'est thierry ardisson et
qu'à part expliqué on ne bouge pas
pendant le jingle assez formidable non
je vais pas vous n'avez pas bouger vous
bien alors vous pensez à quoi là là je
suis en train de me dire quelle va être
la première question l'an dernier la
dernière chose que vous faites avant de
vous coucher je médite avant toujours
aurait bourré pas bourré machin je
m'endors en méditant c'est plus facile
quand on est bourré quand même non non
plus difficile a fait plus que forrest
concentré quoi alors ça dure moins
longtemps
je m'endors vous mettez des bâtons
d'encens sur des pommes la musique
indienne non non pas sur des pommes mais
de l'encens non je brûle de l'encens
dans la maison oui oui oui ça abaisse le
taux de vibrations super important et
vous avez une position particulière non
là je me dit très souvent je fais je
commence un petit peu assis et puis
après je glisse si des petits le matin
quand vous regarder dans la glace vous
dites quoi
la première chose que je fais le matin
que vous dites on se voyant dans la
glace le matin je me dis merci mon dieu
d'être aussi beau et d'avoir autant de
chances d'avoir une aussi jolie vie
d'être dans un pays seigneur est de
gagner de l'argent sans rigoler les gens
je trouve ça épatant sans déconner on
devrait tous se dire ça le matin en se
levant sur tout a commencé en fait avec
beaucoup moins d'argent
oui oui c'est comme ça c'est le gros
cadeau le gros cadeau c'est d'avoir
démarré petit d'ailleurs après le film
j'étais redevenu pauvre g mais moins
bien
ah ouais parce que j'avais fait pauvres
riches repos vre
ah j'ai dit non riesch la riviera
d'accord et mer donc là je bouge plus
vous changeriez coup en vous si vous
aviez une baguette magique
pas vraiment rien du tout parce que ben
ouais moi je crois en dieu
donc je change rien je crois que tout
arrive pour le mieux mon ami thierry je
crois que tout arrive pour lemieux
pouvait rien m'arriver de mieux que
d'être là on ce moment de répondre à des
questions à la con là par exemple quelle
phrase ne supportait pas d'entendre je
suis pas responsable c'est pas moi c'est
pas de ma faute
vous voyez avec mon chef tu vois les
phrases de fonctionnaires c'est
terrifiant pourriez pas de lait frelaté
les phases de fonctionner mais ça n'est
pas non mais c'est vrai c'est d'oeuvre
il ya eu huit l'air a réussi à bas à
brûler
six millions de juifs en fonctionne
arizant les gens que tu vas au procès de
nuremberg à tous les gens disent attend
de quoi m'accuse moi on m'a demandé de
répertorier les juifs le didier moi m'a
demandé de conduire le train vous on m'a
demandé de les descendre du train et on
m'a dit rentre et les larmes jeudi cassé
mois 2 en boule de la dialyse sortait
les cadavres
y'at-il a dû vous prenez une tractopelle
de l'est metella et si c'est ça mais qui
dit
10 de poids on accuse donc tout ce qui
touche ce qui concerne la puissance le
pouvoir le machin ça ça ça me ça me
gonfle terriblement comme si vous étiez
sur une île déserte vous préféreriez
faire l'amour avec une fille très laide
ou un mec très beau sur une île déserte
mais où il y aurait des filles le choix
entre une fille très laide et un mec
très beau et un mec très beaux mecs vous
préfériez quoi j'aurai toujours une
légère préférence pour une chopine est
même un peu moche poids joli trou de
balle est ce que vous êtes déjà senti le
maître du d'autant plus que la femme a
aussi un trop de mal weehawken que ça
sera vraiment dur au mal si je me mets
avec la avec celle qui est moche
on n'a qu'à nous deux là une [ __ ] de
trous de balle et une chopine est on
fait ce qu'on veut
ma lèvre a pas de l'idée que comme tel
oui bon on fait comme ça on part quand
vous êtes vous senti le maître du monde
mais je suis je m derrière
non mais ça ne fait aucun doute eh oui
si j'obtiens la méditation
si on croit en duel et si on se dit
qu'on est un petit peu dieu on en est
pas moins dieu un petit lion n'est pas -
lyon ce n'est pas un lapin pour autant
et dans la flamme d'une bougie à toute
l'essence du feu autant que dans le
soleil
mon ami
oui à lui il est tombé dedans quand il
était un peu modéré si vous restez 24 un
avis vous feriez quoi tu m'en restait 24
heures à vivre quelques jeux je médite
ray pendant 24 heures voilà je serai 24
heures de méditation je me préparerai a
quitté mon corps puisque la mort comme
chacun sait n'existe pas et qu'elle
n'est pas l' inverse de la vie autrement
à tous que tout ce que les gens disent
la mort celle inverse de la naissance
alors je suis les prix j'en arrive à la
vie on suit la vie j'en parle moi dans
le spectacle on peut pas le faire c'est
impensable à la télé mais je parle des
traumatismes de la naissance 4 arrive
que tu viens investir un corps tu rends
compte le bordel que c'est à peine tu
sors la jolie maman quand ça se passe
oui oui mais c'est rien à côté de ce que
je subis l'enfant quand même
non mais j'ai dit à jean decon ans
rigole mais c'est vrai à peine tu sors
la tête de la touffe maternelle tu te
retrouve nez à nez avec le trop de
balles de ta mère tu vois la première
image kate mrc que c'est la première
image qui compte elle va ramer pour
avoir l'autorité plus tard je le dis pas
qu'on lui dise pousser fort là
c'est vrai alors c'est bien là je
réponds bien super salaires dernière
question vous incarnez en quoi banon à
chaque fois dans un jeu là c'est la loi
des des karma c'est un peu ce que j'ai
voulu expliquer dans mon film
la loi du karma fait que tu payes tout
au centime près faut pas en vouloir à un
gros [ __ ] il va payer de tout ce sens
c'est pas dans cette vie ça sera dans la
vie d'après donc où tu charges de karma
positif ta vie et donc dans ta vie
d'après sera encore mieux
on a déjà eu nous tous à des karma
merveilleux pour être ici tous ensemble
dans ce studio en est bénie des dieux se
rend pas compte
et donc si on cherche pas notre
qu'armand va pas régresser on va avoir
une vie encore plus belle encore plus
proches jusqu'à se fondre sur deux ne
l'a vraiment avant qu avec le divin
question mais je vous en prie comment ça
s'appelle cette religion c'est pas une
religion c'est le bouddhisme non non non
c'est une philosophie tout simplement de
vie mais c'est sûrement pas une religion
aucune pancarte qu'une au nombre de
médailles rien toutes les religions 10
quand même à peu près la même chose
même le christianisme jusqu'au vième
siècle c'était quand même un peu
d'accord sur l'idée que cette simulation
sauf que pour avoir de la de toit de la
force sur les puissants de l'époque on a
dit qu'on vivait qu'une seule vie mais
personne n'est content merci